in a previous video we established the
entire solution set for the following
equation
and we saw that all the x's that can
satisfy this equation are a combination
of these x's and these x's here the
reason why i'm
referring to each of them is numeral
numerous x's
is that for any integer value of n
you'll get another solution for any
integer value of n
you'll get another solution what i want
to do in this video is to make things
a little bit more concrete and the way
that we're going to do it
is by exploring all of the x values that
satisfy
this equation that sit in the closed
interval
from negative pi over 2 to
0. so i encourage you like always pause
this video and have a go at it
by yourself before we work through it
together
all right now let's work through this
together
so the first helpful thing is we have
these algebraic expressions we have
things written in terms of pi
let's approximate them all in terms of
decimals
so even pi over 2 we can approximate
that let's see if
pi is approximately 3.14
half of that is approximately 1.57
so we could say this approximately the
closed interval from
negative 1.57 to
zero one negative 1.57 isn't exactly
negative
pi over 2 but it'll hopefully be
suitable for what we're trying to do
here
and now let's see if we can write the
different parts of these expressions
or at least approximate them as decimals
so this could be rewritten as x is
approximately
if you were to take 1 8 times the
inverse cosine
of negative 1 6. i encourage you to
verify this on your own on a calculator
you would get that that's approximately
0.22
and then pi over 4 is approximately
0.785 so this
expression would be approximately 0.22
minus 0.7
times n where n could be any integer
and then this one over here on the right
let me do that in the
yellow x could be approximately equal to
well if this is if this evaluates to
approximately
0.22 then this is just the negative of
it so it's going to be negative
0.22 and then it's plus
what approximately pi over 4 is so
0.785
n and now what we could do is just try
different ends and see if we're starting
above or below this interval and then
see which of the x values actually fall
in this interval
so let's just start here if we just
start at n
equals zero actually when i set up a
little table here
if we have n here and if we have the x
value here
when n is zero well then you don't see
this term and you just get
approximately 0.22
now let's compare that to the interval
the interval the upper bound of that
interval is zero
so this does not sit in the interval so
this is too
high and we would want to define the x's
that sit in the interval we want to find
lower values so it's good that here
we're subtracting
0.785 so i would use positive integer
values of
n to decrease this 0.22
here so when n equals 1 we would
subtract
0.785 from that and i'll round all of
these to the hundredths place
and that would get us to negative
0.57 and that does
sit in the interval so this looks good
so this would be a solution
in that interval right over here and
let's try n
equals 2 so we would subtract 0.785
again and that would get us to
negative one point three five
not two five three five
and that also sits in the interval it's
larger than negative one point five
seven so that looks good
let's subtract 0.785 again when n
equals 3 that would get us negative 2.14
well that's all of a sudden out of the
interval because that's below the lower
bound here
so this is too low so we've
using this expression we've been able to
find
two x values that sit in the interval
that we cared about
now let's use this x these x values
right over here and i'll set up another
table so let's see we have our n and
then we have our x values
so let's start with n equals 0 because
that's easy to compute and then this
term would go away and we'd have
negative
0.22 and that's actually
in this interval here it's below zero
it's larger than negative 1.57
so that one checks out but now to really
explore we have to go in both directions
we have to
increase it or decrease it so if we
wanted to increase it we could have a
situation where n
equals 1. so if n equals 1 we're going
to add 0.785 to this
now you immediately know that that's
going to be a positive value if you
computed it
it'd be 0.57 which is larger than zero
so this is too high so now we could try
going lower than
negative 0.22 by having negative values
of n
so if n is equal to negative 1 that
means we're subtracting
0.785 from this right over here
which would get us to negative
1.01 well that one works out
so that's in our interval and now let's
subtract 0.785 again so i'll have n
equals negative 2 and so if i subtract
0.785 again i could round that to
negative
1.79
which is lower than negative 1.57 so
it's out of our interval so it's
too low so all of the x values
that are in our interval that satisfy
this equation
are these two right over here and this
one
and this one and we are done